In order to give a good impression at an interview,...
...it is best to arrive at least 10 minutes before the start.
When greeting someone, make sure that your handshake is firm,...
...that you make eye contact, and that you have a friendly expression.
Don't avoid eye contact during the interview,...
...and don't slouch or fidget in your seat.
Ask if you haven't understood something clearly.
An interview is not a one-way street.
Behave in a respectful manner, but also evaluate your interviewers,...
...and think critically about the values of the organization and how you are treated.
Be clear about the hiring process and what happens next,...
...i.e. when and from whom to expect a call.
Don't give the appearance that you are desperate for work...
...and that you would take any job.
Switch your cell phone off during the interview.
Take responsibilities for your decisions and don't come up with excuses.
Looking for work can be hard and may take its toll on you,...
...but never show your frustrations and stay positive.